Thanks to the latest research
into violent expiratory events -
or, sneezes -
we can now observe
in very close detail
the “turbulent multiphase cloud”
which distributes a payload
of droplets and
mucosalivary ligaments,
or, well, stringy gobs of spit,
at high speeds
and over great distances.
These gross but engrossing images
are made possible by highly
sensitive, slow-motion cameras
which can track
each single speck of snot.
This is high-tech stuff, but
the fascination with sneezing
and the attempt to capture
and examine the sneeze
is actually as old as the
moving image itself.
This short film, known as Fred Ott’s
Sneeze, was recorded in 1894
to test a new moving picture machine
called the Kinetoscope.
This five-second long film,
showing Fred Ott taking a pinch
of snuff and then sneezing,
captured the imagination of a public
who were wowed by the idea that
something as fast as a sneeze
could now be captured, preserved
and repeated.
Of course, sneezes were also
an object of fascination
long before the cinema.
For the ancient Greeks, sneezes
could be an omen from the gods.
According to one
ancient Roman doctor,
sneezing during sex could
be used as a contraceptive.
But the most common
interpretation of a sneeze
is probably that you might
be getting ill.
But it was not until
the late 19th Century
that the idea that
infectious diseases
can be caused by microscopic
pathogens was introduced.
It was this new understanding
of how disease is spread,
along with the global shock
of the Spanish Flu pandemic in 1918,
that spawned the public health
messages that we know today,
like, “Coughs and sneezes
spread diseases.”
It was the development of
stroboscopic photography in the 1930s
which really brought
this message home.
This work, led by the MIT
researcher Harold Edgerton,
used short sharp flashes of
light to seemingly freeze time
and analyse all sorts
of high-speed phenomena,
including the humble sneeze.
Images like this one helped us to
understand the raw power of sneezes,
and to think about how
we might protect ourselves
and those around us.
An infectious sneeze can
be dangerous at any time.
But the prospect of a
wave of viral infections
was particularly worrying to public
health officials in the UK
during the Second World War
who were keen to protect the health
of those working in the war effort.
Wartime propaganda made good
use of these stroboscopic sneezes
to persuade people to cover
their mouths and wear masks.
The germ mask is a simple
way of keeping the germs at bay.
Get one and wear it now.
In the age of SARS and COVID-19,
cutting-edge technology
is still being used
to try to better capture
and visualise
the mechanics of the sneeze.
Maybe an even fuller understanding
of exactly how a sneeze works
will help us to use tools like
masks and social distancing
more effectively in the fight
against epidemics.
But it’s not only researchers
who are continuing
the long tradition
of filming sneezes.
A quick search on
a video streaming site
will bring up homemade footage
from vloggers and filmmakers,
all capturing these explosive
moments for themselves.
The image of the sneeze
is with us to stay.
Yes, it can provide us
with useful information,
but it can also be a comic punchline,
a tool for persuasion,
or just a source of fascination.
It’s something that
is common to us all,
yet it is also so strange,
spontaneous and fast
that we never really get to see it.
Maybe capturing it on film,
repeating it, and slowing it down,
gives us a measure of control -
or at least the illusion of control -
that we can’t have in real time.
And so in well over a century since
Fred Ott’s Sneeze,
in some respects
our viewing habits haven’t
really changed so much after all.